Transcriptor: Juan Carlos Borja
Revisor: Analia Padin
(Lengua de señas)
Tranquilos, sí hablo.
Quiero preguntarles, ¿quién me entendió
lo que acabo de decir ahora?
Levanten la mano los que me entendieron.
¿Nadie? OK.
Ahora, quiero que piensen por un minuto,
¿qué es lo que sintieron cuando pasé
y empecé a hablar en lengua de señas?
Quiero que lo piensen por un momento.
Existen más de 64 000 personas sordas
registradas en el CONADIS,
en el Consejo de Discapacidad,
aquí en el Ecuador.
Tal vez 64 000 personas no suene mucho,
pero 64 000 personas equivalen
a llenar seis universidades como esta.
Completitas; seis Católicas.
Y un poquito más.
Obviamente, yo tampoco sabía nada de esto,
ni de la lengua de señas,
ni de cultura de personas sordas,
hasta que decidí estudiar
educación especial
con un enfoque en lengua de señas
para personas sordas.
Muchas, pero muchas personas me preguntan
por qué decidí enfocarme
en una carrera tan diferente como esta.
Claramente, aquí en el Ecuador
no hay esa carrera.
Es por eso que yo decidí
ir a estudiar al extranjero,
súper feliz, emocionada
de vivir una nueva experiencia,
conocer nueva gente.
Así es que, en el 2010,
tomo un vuelo y me voy a EE.UU.
Cuando llego a EE.UU,
me estaba esperando mi familia anfitriona,
o mi "host family" como se conoce.
Aquí les presento a mi "host family".
Cuando los veo, saludo a mamá, a papá,
a los tres chicos de atrás,
que son mis hermanos,
y a Ali, mi hermana.
Muy feliz me acerco,
les saludo y todos me abrazan.
Ya se imaginarán, fue muy emotivo.
Pero en eso Ali se me acerca y me dice:
"Hola, Damaris. ¿Cómo estás?
Mi nombre es Ali,
y soy tu nueva hermana".
Pero fue más de la siguiente manera:
(Lengua de señas)
Correcto, mi hermana era sorda.
O es sorda, ¿no?
Cuando vi eso,
tuve la misma cara que Uds. hicieron
cuando empecé a hablar en lengua de señas.
Mi cara y mi reacción
fueron diferentes, raras.
De todas maneras, empezamos
a conversar, en lo que se podía,
y en la cena me empezaron a explicar
que, en efecto, Ali es una persona sorda,
Ali es una persona
que utiliza lengua de señas,
y es la forma de comunicarse entre ellos.
Mamá, papá y hermanos,
todos son oyentes como nosotros,
pero también dominan la lengua de señas.
Entonces veo ahí a todo mundo
hablando en lengua de señas,
y en ese momento yo me sentí
la persona más excluida en el mundo.
Y en ese momento dije: "Tengo que aprender
lengua de señas y lo voy a hacer".
¿Y qué me motivó muchísimo a aprender?
Primero, que todos sabían lengua de señas,
y luego porque hasta el perro
entendía lengua de señas.
Es por eso que empiezo estudiar,
Ali se convirtió en mi mejor amiga,
y mi hermana mayor.
Fue la persona que me enseñó a manejar,
me enseñó a manejar moto,
me hizo el tour en la universidad,
me llevaba a conocer los restaurantes,
me llevaba a abrir mi cuenta en el banco.
Ya se imaginan todo ese shock
cultural que yo tenía,
y toda esa experiencia la viví con Ali.
Al convivir con ella aprendí muchísimo.
Aprendí mucho de las personas sordas,
aprendí de la comunidad,
aprendí de su cultura,
aprendí de cómo ellos viven,
y de la lengua de señas.
Algo que me impactó mucho mi vida
fue que, como aquí y en muchos países,
no todos saben lengua de señas,
por lo que ella ocupaba el servicio
de intérprete en lengua de señas,
que cumple el rol de ser el intérprete
entre la persona sorda y la oyente.
El intérprete de lengua de señas
me impactó tanto,
generó un gran impacto en mi vida,
conocer a alguien así,
que decidí estudiar para ser
una intérprete de lengua de señas.
Por tal motivo estudié educación especial
con un enfoque en lengua de señas.
Pasaron los años,
después de 5 años me gradué,
una hermosa experiencia,
pero no todo acaba ahí.
El gran reto empieza
cuando regreso a Ecuador.
Y yo regreso muy feliz
con todo lo que aprendí,
quería compartir mi hermosa experiencia,
quería ser ese puente de comunicación
para las personas sordas,
y brindar un gran apoyo para todos ellos.
¿Qué creen que pasó cuando vine a Ecuador?
Mi carrera no existe todavía.
Ya han pasado cinco años.
Entonces dije: "No, ¿saben qué?, OK.
No lo hay aquí en el Ecuador.
Está difícil hacer algo relacionado
con apoyar a la comunidad sorda;
no hay problema".
A los 22 años decidí empezar
mi propia fundación.
Fundación Salud Un Nuevo Comienzo.
¿Cuál es el enfoque de nuestra fundación?
Queríamos llegar a más personas,
a más docentes, capacitadores,
que puedan conocer sobre la inclusión,
sobre lo que es una persona sorda,
sobre la lengua de señas.
Y estábamos llegando, hacíamos viajes,
capacitábamos a profesores.
Después de todo el trabajo
que se estaba haciendo,
yo sentía que algo hacía falta todavía.
Sentía que, pese a estar ayudando
a una gran comunidad,
a personas con discapacidad auditiva,
el resto de las personas como nosotros,
teníamos que conocer.
Quería que Uds. conozcan
el mundo del que yo me enamoré,
el mundo que me encantó,
y el mundo con el cual trabajo.
Así es como en mi proyecto y en mi cabeza,
se me ocurre hacer un lugar inclusivo.
Les pregunto, ¿qué pasaría si Uds.,
saliendo de aquí, van y visitan un lugar,
donde las personas que atienden no oyen?
Donde Uds., al llegar y sentarse,
y quieren pedir un café,
lo tienen que hacer en lengua de señas,
y no saben cómo hacerlo.
Quiero que piensen cómo se sentirían.
Precisamente eso fue lo que quise crear
cuando empecé con este lindo proyecto
llamado Café en Señas.
¿Y qué hacemos en Café en Señas?
Es una cafetería inclusiva
donde personas sordas trabajan,
donde ellos te atienden,
donde tú vas, pides un café y te lo dan,
pero tú eres la persona
que tiene que adaptarse a su mundo.
¿Qué hacemos en Café en Señas?
Bueno, aparte de ser una cafetería,
nosotros celebramos cumpleaños,
nosotros hacemos eventos
en diferentes actividades,
nosotros hacemos karaoke
en lengua de señas.
Sí, amigos, las personas sordas cantan.
Sí, y son unas de las experiencias
más lindas que me llevo.
Algo que me impactó muchísimo,
al momento de crear Café en Señas,
fue al momento de la contratación.
Publicamos en redes sociales,
nos reunimos con personas sordas
a las que entrevistamos,
y bueno, le pregunto a Patty,
una chica que trabaja con nosotros,
y le digo: "¿Cómo te enteraste
de la publicación que hicimos?".
Me dijo: "Bueno, entre amigos
nos pasamos la voz".
No exactamente la voz,
pero entre amigos se comunicaron.
Y lo que Patty me dijo fue:
"Muchísimas gracias
por esta gran oportunidad.
Esta es la primera vez que mi discapacidad
es un requerimiento para algo".
Imagínense el gran impacto que yo sentí
cuando Patty me dijo esto.
Empezamos con el proyecto,
tuvo una gran acogida,
van personas oyentes
como nosotros, que no sabemos,
entran a la cafetería
y se llevan una gran experiencia.
O por lo menos aprenden una nueva seña.
Y eso es lo que queremos lograr
con Café en Señas.
Lo que Uds. sintieron
cuando yo me paré aquí
y empecé a hablar con las manos,
es lo que las personas sordas
sienten todo el tiempo.
Ese sentimiento tal vez de angustia,
de ansiedad, de desesperación,
de no saber lo que Damaris
me estaba diciendo con las manos.
Eso es lo que ellos sienten
todos los días.
Y genera incluso aislamiento para ellos.
E imagínense, las personas sordas
no eligieron ser sordas.
Ellos no eligen ser sordos,
nadie elige tener una cierta condición.
Y eso me hace pensar si quienes de verdad
tenemos la discapacidad somos nosotros.
Porque, teniendo la capacidad de aprender,
de hacer algo nuevo, no lo hacemos.
Y bueno, ¿ahora qué?
El proyecto muy lindo, muy inclusivo,
pero ¿ahora qué?
¿Qué estás haciendo tú?
¿Qué están haciendo Uds. para crear
un cambio positivo en la sociedad?
Tal vez con estas pequeñas acciones
no estoy cambiando el mundo,
pero sí cambié la vida de Patty.
¿Verdad?
Quiero que salgamos más allá
de este proyecto inclusivo.
Y quiero que de verdad pensemos un momento
en qué pasaría si mañana despertamos,
salimos a la calle y todas las personas
empiezan a hablar en lengua de señas.
Y cada uno de Uds. es la persona rara,
la que tiene que encajar en un mundo.
Tal vez así podamos educar a nuestra mente
que ser diferente es normal y está bien.
¿Qué estamos enseñando
a nuestros hijos, a nuestros amigos,
a nuestros empleados?
Pero de verdad pensemos por un momento,
¿qué legado les estamos dejando
el día de mañana cuando no estemos aquí?
¿Tal vez una educación
en un aula de clase es suficiente?
Yo creo que no.
Yo creo que mostrar la realidad como es
vale mucho más que estar aprendiendo
atrás de un sillón o de una pizarra.
Importante, pero demos ese paso adicional,
hagamos algo más,
salgamos de esta zona de comfort
donde nos sentimos cómodos y nos gusta,
y arriesguémonos a hacer
cosas nuevas y diferentes.
De verdad espero que todos encuentren
una Ali en su vida como yo lo hice.
Y si no la encuentran, sean esa Ali
en la vida de alguien.
Hagan ese cambio.
Y no es difícil, me van a preguntar:
"Pero Damaris, yo no sé lengua de señas,
cómo comunicarme con una persona sorda.
¿Cómo hablo con la persona
de al lado mío si me da nervios?".
Da ese paso extra. Solo hazlo.
Y no tienes que saber lengua de señas
para hablar con una persona sorda.
¿Qué es lo mejor que puedes hacer?
Sé una persona paciente,
sé una persona con mente abierta,
sé una persona que quiere lograr
un cambio en esta vida.
Y los cambios empiezan desde nosotros.
Quisiera enseñarles unas señas
para que por lo menos,
si es que esto no les quedó, o se olvidan,
aprendan tres señas que quiero enseñar.
¿Está bien? Así que vamos,
vamos a repetir conmigo.
Una de las señas que más me gusta,
y creo que te puede abrir el camino
al mundo increíble de las personas sordas,
vamos a aprender gracias
y vamos a repetir. Hagámoslo.
La primera es gracias. Gracias, perfecto.
La segunda es por favor. Por favor.
Y la tercera es te quiero.
Y bueno, para las personas
que se preguntaban
qué es lo que dije
con las manos cuando llegué,
dije lo siguiente:
"Mi superpoder es saber
lengua de señas, ¿cuál es el tuyo?".
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)